Good morning, Hank.
It's Tuesday, October 27th, 2015, a significant
day in YouTube history because tomorrow, YouTube
Red launches, which may or may not change
online video forever.
Also, you'll notice that I trimmed my beard
because Nerdfighters had started to refer
to it as the Under Puff.
Right, but YouTube Red.
So until now, YouTube has always been like
network television and radio before it - an
advertising-supported medium.
Now there are obvious advantages to this.
Creators get paid unlike most social media
sites, and also, it's free for viewers.
But there are also disadvantages.
Ad-supported media tends to seek the broadest
possible audience because what advertisers
really want is the most possible eyeballs
to see their message.
And with ad-supported media, we generally
end up with stuff that lots of people will
watch over stuff that, like, some people will
really, really love.
You know like broad spectrum shows like Law
& Order can succeed, but niche shows like
Firefly or Arrested Development can't.
Also, I know you probably don't think you're
affected by advertising, but you are.
To quote Emily Nussbaum's brilliant recent
essay on what advertising has done to television,
"Our comfort with being sold to may look like
savvy, but it feels like innocence."
I mean, Hank, corporations know a lot more
about what influences my consumptive habits
than I do.
That phenomenon has been studied extensively,
sources in the dooblydoo, where you can also
find a link to Nussbaum's essay.
So OK, having acknowledged my advertising
ambivalence, let's explore my YouTube Red
ambivalence.
Here's the idea - for ten dollars a month,
you get ad-free YouTube, off-line watching,
and all the music you want.
So it's like Spotify plus ad-free YouTube.
Also, there will be some new original shows
from people like PewDiePie and other YouTubers
that are only available to YouTube Red subscribers.
So Hank, the question I've heard the most
from people is "Is this good for creators?"
which speaks a lot to how awesome the YouTube
viewership is.
The answer to that question is... yeah?
Some portion of that ten dollars per month
will go to the YouTubers you watch, I don't
really know how much yet.
And per viewer, YouTube Red will generate
more money for creators than advertising.
That said, it's like a thousand times more
valuable to support a creator through Patreon
or through buying merch than through either
YouTube Red or advertising.
Actually, it's not like a thousand, it is
a thousand times better.
Maybe even two thousand.
The best way to financially support creators
you care about remains directly.
So I don't think that's the reason to get
YouTube Red.
But I do think there are good reasons.
I mean I'm gonna get it.
But anyway Hank, here's what concerns me the
most: will YouTube Red create two classes
of YouTube viewers - those who can pay and
those who can't?
One of the things that makes YouTube really
special is that at it's best, it's a flat
platform for both creators and audiences,
right?
Like I have the same capacity to reach an
audience sitting here in my basement as a
major media company does.
And on the audience side, if you have access
to a device and the internet, all of YouTube
is available to you.
Now that started to change a little on the
creator side of things as production values
have risen, but I really don't want it to
change on the audience side.
Like YouTube is gonna remain essentially the
same for everyone who doesn't become a Red
subscriber.
The only difference is that you won't have
access to these new high-budget original shows.
Like PewDiePie is making a horror show with
the producers of The Walking Dead, and that
sounds awesome!
And it would also be completely impossible
in an advertising-supported medium.
But Nerdfighters, I wonder if you would be
excited or scared if your favorite creators
did such a show.
I'm asking for a friend by the way.
Like, it allows creators to have the kinds
of budgets you can't have for advertising-supported
projects, but on the other hand, it limits
the number of people who can actually see
the thing to Red subscribers.
In short Hank, I don't know how to feel about
all this stuff.
We've always been uncomfortable with advertising,
and it's nice to see YouTube moving away from
sole reliance upon it.
But I think YouTube Red will be a good option
for a lot of people without harming the experience
of the majority who stick with ad-supported
YouTube.
And in general, I think that subscriptions
make viewers more powerful and brands slightly
less so.
And that's good news.
But I'm not sure I want YouTube to look like
cable TV when it grows up.
I want YouTube to be driven by the stuff that
makes it interesting, by passionate fan communities
who do awesome stuff together by the direct
relationship between creator and audience.
I mean, at it's best, YouTube isn't something
you watch; it's something you're part of.
So the question becomes, is YouTube Red a
step toward that promise land or away from
it?
I don't know.
That's not a rhetorical question.
I look forward to continuing the conversation
in comments, Nerdfighters.
Hank, I'll see you tomorrow.
Nope, Friday.
Gosh, I was so in Brotherhood 2.0 mode.